let's get to read on all of this now
from former acting ice director and
former U.S border Patrol Chief Ron
patello Ron uh just just this this
notion that Magnus is pushing back as
hard as he is I saw a quote where he
says to my orcas I expressed to him that
I felt there was no justification for me
to resign when I still care deeply about
the work I was doing and felt that the
work was focused on the things I was
hired to do in the first place that last
part of the sentence is interesting what
I mean because maybe he is doing the
bidding of the White House this is a
White House that really is rolled out
the red carpet uh you know for unlimited
migration through the southern borders
and and is he just the Fall Guy here
it remains to be seen I mean let's think
about why he's there Charles he's a
progressive police chief who was very
critical of the previous administration
in their border policy and was on the
record in a number of places saying that
he didn't want to cooperate uh local
authorities with ice so he's on record
saying that he wants to continue to have
an immigration system that's broken if
you don't have a credible immigration
system how are you going to control the
border and how has he done since he's
been there we are in the worst surge
along the Southwest border for our
illegal immigration in the history of
the country we have 60 000 Americans
dying every year from opioid overdose so
there's no there's that's a not a
coincidence right we have this
uncontrolled flow at the border and we
have people dying all over the country
hundreds a week right and and what's
this public face to the rest of us you
know as far as I can tell his largest
press conference in front of the
American people was on a fake news story
about horse Patrol agents in Del Rio who
are accused of a crime that they did not
commit uh that's his public face so
that's what the workforce sees that's
what the rest of us have seen how about
a 40-minute press conference about how
he's going to secure the border and by
the way he serves at the pleasure of the
president a cabinet secretary has asked
him to step down for whatever reason
whatever the justification he serves at
the pleasure of the president sure we're
not talking about the Border here we're
not talking about the men and women of
CBP who took an oath and are dedicated
to securing the Border we're now being
distracted by rearranging the deck
chairs on the Titanic we have a terrible
crisis going on the border and we're
talking about who the the leader at CBP
is going to be that the workforce
deserves better than this and and again
let me jump in here for a moment can can
the workforce expect better because see
your point in December 2017 he published
a New York Times op-ed
very critical of Donald Trump and Jeff
sessions with respect to Sanctuary
cities saying a complicated police
forces this was the ideal guide for the
administration right he checked all
their immigration boxes so should the
folks at the border patrol brace for
someone even further to the left or is
this just for public consumption that
nothing really will change
the policy at the border is all wrong
yeah so there is a danger right this is
part of the distraction people on men
and women at CBP that have taken a note
they want action they don't need this
distraction we need a plan for the
Border we need to secure that border and
he has failed to do it uh he I'm sure
he's not setting the policy this
Administration ripped up all of the
tools that we had before they took over
now again we're seeing the worst thing
we've ever seen and now we're talking
about who the commissioner is going to
be instead of what the plans are to
secure the U.S border is there any hope
though that this will change I mean this
has been a prominent uh piece of news
obviously it's it's it had impact with
the elections and this Administration
has had a 10 error the whole time I mean
I honestly believe this has to be what
they want to see this has to be
fulfilling some sort of progressive
dream of open borders and people
flooding through
without well the workforce definitely
deserves better our country deserves
better think about the celebration today
for all of our veterans and here we are
with the Border that's out of control
but they they went out and gave
everything to protect us and now look
what we're doing at our own selfless
border I agree Ron thank you so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else